bien une chose que je comprends pas
quand je reçois votre livre c'est
pourquoi ne pas avoir signé botton
puisque c'est toujours votre nom
aujourd'hui avoir signé noir
compte tenu des accusations que vous
portez dans ce livre contre votre père
ce que je pense que ce livre d'abord
c'est une histoire entre mon père et moi
tout simplement et
on s'excuse le sens avec noir non c'est
mon nom je jette marié pierre botton
vous appelez beau temps je dis c'est
pareil
mon mari est pourquoi vivre aux états
unis
écoutez quand on voit ce que j'ai vécu
ce que mes enfants vécu il ya un moment
il fallait dire stop
voilà mes enfants souffraient
terriblement et moi aussi j'ai préféré
tout coupé coupé les ponts et les
réflexions près les enfants à l'école
j'étais trop ça n'allait plus ouais
alors vous êtes aux états unis donc vous
êtes debout que dans une agence de
mannequins c'est ça travaille dans le
milieu de la mode
ouais et là vous êtes en france donc
pour la sortie de ce bouquin alors vous
êtes effectivement j'ai écrit ce livre
non pas pour régler des comptes mais
pour dire stop
mais en fait la sphère bouton l1 peu aux
oubliettes en fait c'est vous qui la
remet tait la surface parce que il ya eu
la sortie du livre de pierre botton
qu'on a reçues ici d'ailleurs mais
disons que la faire aller enterrer la
pourquoi d'un seul coup ça laissait
vraiment je vous dis une fois encore une
fois c'est entre mon père et moi je
crois qu'il ya une il s'est passé des
événements
il s'est passé que je suis donc parti il
ya 3 ans et l'année dernière au mois de
février
mon père a envoyé quelqu'un à l'école de
mes enfants
voilà et ça m'a beaucoup choqué par faut
renouer un contact avec vous oui enfin
la personne était ma soeur m'a dit je
sais pas peut-être une dizaine de fois
c'est je suis pas l'envoyer de mapa donc
voila voila et si vous voulez c'est
arrivé après je me suis rendu compte que
ça arrivait à un moment qui pour lui
était crucial puisque après par la suite
j'ai appris que
il rentra en politique vous pensez qu'en
side et cherché à renouer avec vous pour
finalement relancé sa carrière politique
pour pourra rendre pour s'arranger
elle arrange et que effectivement il est
c'était une caution mais moi je ne me
servirai pas de caution bien alors ce
bouquin est très intéressant parce qu'on
voit finalement toute cette histoire
racontée par quelqu'un qui a été témoin
numéro un c'est le cas de le dire donc
au début on voit c'est à ce gears est où
sa première campagne électorale toute la
famille s'y met vous répondent au
téléphone vous mettez des tracts dans
les enveloppes enfin tout ça et c est
assez joyeux et dès que votre père était
lui le regard des autres sur vous
changent effectivement vous donner la
fille du député vous dites vous devenez
un mini toit en parlant de votre père
donc on voit bien déjà le la première
rupture elle est là c'est à dire que
d'un seul coup on vous regarde plus
comme avant une rupture vous savez à
l'époque je crois que c'était pas du
tout perçue comme ça on était très fier
de ce qui se passait on n'était pas du
tout au contraire on était très impliqué
comme effectivement je le raconte on
faisait la chaîne pour nous enveloppe
ensuite on allait distribuer moi j'étais
vraiment une militante j'ai affiché pour
lui j'ai fait un coup de choses et c'est
pas ça la rupture je crois que la
rupture elle est venue plus tard on va
en parler
donc ensuite on voit l'arrivée de pierre
botton dans le cercle familial première
altercation violente avec votre père
quand vous l'annoncer votre volonté
d'arrêter vos études et d'entrer dans la
vie active et là effectivement d'un coup
le papa gentil devient assez hard
il ya une espèce de bousculades entre
vous il vous dit tu vas continuer des
études et si tu le fais pas je
refuserais que tu t'appelles plus
longtemps noir ou c'est vrai que d'un
seul coup le mec c'est un peu le frimas
il vous a mis à la porte vous a demandé
de lui rendre les clés de la maison
alors en 86 vous avez 21 ans
votre père devient ministre vous
commencé à fréquenter d'une façon un peu
plus assidus pierre botton avec qui vous
travaillez puisque effectivement vous
quittez l'école et vous quittez vos
études arrêtez de vous donne un boulot
de de secrétariat auprès de lui et
botton pierre botton finira par vous
demander en mariage
je ne comprends pas poser des problèmes
avec votre père dont déjà on sent bien
que ça arrive
ce jour des problèmes la fille aînée
mais voilà avec son père c'est pas trés
c'est pas quelqu'un si vous voulez chez
nous il n'y avait pas de dialogue avec
discussion où il y avait rien c'était un
père très autoritaire
apparemment oui trés trés tyrannique
mais je pense qu'il faut le dire et
c'est vrai que vous racontez des
vacances à saint tropez ou lui il joue
du violoncelle et il fait régner un
ordre de faire parce que ça le dérange
ou et donc vous épousez quand même un
des plus proches collaborateurs de votre
père c'est à dire que malgré ce sont ces
problèmes qu'on sent arriver vous vous
épousez un proche collaborateur donc
effectivement ça pouvait arriver où
c'est arrivé non attendez je crois que
c'était totalement différent quand j'ai
épousé la personne que j'aimais et voilà
c'est tout c'est ça n'a aucun sens
n'avait rien à voir avec mon père
c'était totalement différent de nouveaux
problèmes surgissent lorsque vous vous
mariez effectivement avec pierre botton
c'est à dire que la cérémonie vous avez
l'impression qu'elle est transformée en
opération de relations publiques pour
lui compliquer oui complètement donc il
se sert et c'est tout ce que vous lui
reprochez finalement dans ce bouquin
c'est de se servir de tout le monde
il fait passer sa carrière politique
avant tout 1 et parallèlement ce que je
disais en commençant il tient un
discours sur la morale sur le fait qu'il
faut pas vendre son âme etc
il tient officiellement un discours très
très humanitaire est très voilà et puis
quand on voit la vie privée c'est tout à
fait différent en 88 votre père michel
noir perd son ministère il n'a plus
d'appartements de fonction il va dans un
appartement rue de solferino qui est
payé par pierre botton et il dira plus
tard au juge qu'en fait c'est un
appartement qui vous était destiné et
que vous n'aviez pas pour un caprice
comme ça ce vous ne vouliez plus ça fait
à m tout au long de cette affaire il ya
eu un des allers retours entre lui et
moi c'est à dire que le juge faisait
trier entre ce que disait la fille ce
que disait le père parce
qu'effectivement mon père se rabattait
systématiquement sur moi ces services
vous aussi pour sa défense on va le voir
la même année les relations donc ses
88es relations se dégradent entre michel
noir et pierre botton ne sache je crois
que ça c'est entre eux déjà c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose que je peux mais
c'est vrai que je pense que mon père est
quelqu'un qui utilise les gens
complètement
c'est un vrai je dirais c'est un pur
politique voilà l'utiliser et après
quand il ne peut pas se regarder dans la
glace et dire j'y suis arrivé moi même
fait le ménage plus ou moins plus ou
moins bien plus ou moins avec la classe
mais c'est quand même le mélange alors
bon finalement pierre botton fini par
quitter ses fonctions à l'hôtel de ville
de lyon
mais avant il demande à votre père de
lui signer une reconnaissance de dette
puisqu'il est financé toutes sont
exploités je ne sais pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé
ah bon c'est pas du tout je veux dire le
la reconnaissance de dette est ce qu on
appelle ce qu'on a appelé le protocole
est un document que moi j'ai vu arriver
chez moi à un moment où donc
pierre était parti et c'est quelque
chose que mon père a écrit et envoyé
comme ça et c'est pas du tout je veux
dire on n'oblige pas michel noir à
écrire quoi que ce soit
et alors là bon jeu qu'on apprend dans
ce bouquin c'est que votre mari pierre
botton vit une aventure il vous cocufie
il vit une aventure avec la fille d'un
personnage important de la république
dont vous citer le nom dans votre
bouquin et là vous êtes désespéré
évidemment ou ccc tragique pour vous et
vous écrivez trois pages sur un agenda
trois pages qui seront produites par
votre père vous l'écrivez dans un moment
de déprime et c'est tout le coeur de la
faire c'est page que vous écrivez dans
un mode en ce moment comme ça d'abandon
seront produites par votre père à la
barre pour sa défense en fait ouais
alors votre mari il a des ennuis pierre
botton il se retrouve en prison en garde
à vue à puis après en prison vous
appelez votre père pour lui dire attends
tu peux pas laisser pierre mon mari est
un ancien collaborateur en prison et
vous découvrez en fait qu'il a aucune
envie de défendre il vous dit la police
possède des éléments très vague il a
fait des conneries donc excuse moi mais
plus personne ne peut rien pour lui
il vous demande même de vous séparer de
votre mari et je crois que mon père a eu
dans toute cette histoire une attitude
purement égoïste
il a essayé de si vous voulez me
récupérer effectivement à un moment qui
était qui était important pour lui
il a souhaité faire ce que je raconte il
a souhaité faire un noël en 1992 pour
les enfants parce que j'ai deux enfants
et donc il m'a demandé de venir et de
participer à noël
j'y suis allé et mon père a souhaité me
parler
donc je l'aï vu et m'a demandé de
divorcer et donc je suis parti avec mais
voilà et l'a donc vu et entendu
voilà mon père votre père michel noir on
la commence à accuser botton il dit en
fait si j'ai eu des relations avec lui
c'est uniquement parce qu'il était mon
gendre l'appartement de la rue de
solferino en fait s'il n'était pas pour
moi même si beau temps de payer 1000 été
pour ma fille donc pour vous à ce
moment-là botton remet au juste cette
fameuse reconnaissance de dette est en
fait en dix ans et c'est là le coeur de
la sphère il dit en fait je n'ai signé
ce papier que parce que botton me
menacer de quitter ma fille et elle se
serait alors suicidée
et pour prouver ses dires y produit et
c'est bien l'objet de votre bouquin il
produit ses trois pages que vous aviez
écrit comme je le dis dans un moment
d'abattement en découvrant en découvrant
vous étiez cocu même le juge ait choqué
quand votre père sort ces sorciers mais
je crois que tout le monde a été choqué
c'est un acte qui est inqualifiable
on ne fait pas ça si vous voulez je
pense que le rôle d'un père c'est quand
même de protéger ses enfants mais pas
des enfants au moins pour s'en servir
comme bouclier et je pense que c'est ce
que mon père hafez il a sacrifié sa
fille pour essayer de s'en sortir alors
qu en face de lui il y avait toutes les
preuves et si vous voulez plus dense est
dans cette histoire enfin je veux dire
il y avait il y avait trois pièces
étaient de l'être et je veux dire il a
il a lu que ce qui l'arrangeait donc
c'est un petit peu en fait le dos au mur
pour se défendre pour assurer sa défense
le dos au mur il finit par produire ces
lettres alors en plus ce qui est
horrible c'est que c'est des documents
vous aviez confié à votre grand père
votre grand-père bon était vieux était
malade et un jour ils vous appellent des
coups tu devrais venir récupérer tes
papiers et vous découvrez à ce moment là
que votre propre mère avait soustrait
cesser ces pages de l'agenda à votre
grand père donc elle les avait
évidemment il avait donné à votre père
pour qui les utilise dans son procès
alors un truc est bizarre dans votre
bouquin c'est que vous semblez plus en
vouloir à votre père qu'à votre mère jeu
quand on lit le bouquin c'est kampot
mère quitte à les voler ses lettres chez
votre grand père ac c'est ma mère qui
est totalement appris appris ces
documents mais si vous voulez ce que ce
que je vous savez entreprendre quelque
chose et avoir une utilisation tél il ya
une différence
jeudi ils pouvaient très bien les
prendre et puis pas les utiliser surtout
que c'était pas c'était quelque chose
qui avait été écrit un autre moment
oui vous étiez dans l'avion voilà ce
qu'ils n'avaient absolument pas été
écrit au moment où soi-disant il a été
écrit le protocole est donc si vous
voulez alors au tribunal la production
de ces lettres vous vivez ça vous c'est
normal comme un coup de poignard dans ce
courrier sortir ces lettres ont été
confiés à votre grand père vous les
voyez sortir en plein en plein prétoire
vous comprenez bien à ce moment là que
votre père vous sacrifier la politique
et vous prenez la décision de porter
plainte pour pour vol contre
à l'époque j'avais pas les plaindre tout
à fait vous savez j'ai ce jour là je
crois que le ciel m'est tombé sur la
tête quoi ça marche ça a été l'horreur
l'horreur parce que je pensais pas qu
ils étaient capables de faire beaucoup
de choses mais je pensais pas qu'il
était capable d'aller si loin
après donc c'est un mec très décidés à
faire n'importe quoi quand même alors si
je ne sais qu'il a fait de la prison
votre l'a écrit jeudi a été acquitté de
tous il a été il a complété condamné à
de la prison avec sursis il a été
condamné surtout je pense que c'est la
chose qui me touche le plus à cinq ans
d'inéligibilité et il aimerait
financièrement une amende si j'agis donc
en fait rien quoi si ce n'est
l'inéligibilité pire que tout et puis de
toute façon je ne souhaite la prison à
personne justement justement votre mari
pierre botton banc en prison est le
calvaire pour vous continue parce que ce
qui est terrible c'est vraiment un
calvaire c'est le cas de le dire ce que
vous allez le voir en prison il vous
reproche des choses et vous il vous dit
que vous êtes de mèche avec les autres
enfin c'est à dire il vous dit un jour
j'ai plus confiance en toi
oui mais ça je crois que vous savez la
prison est quelque chose qui qui qui
détruit tout qui détruit tout repère qui
détruit absolument tout et il vouera
complice des autres oui mais qui va se
suicider il a fait une tentative alors
le vous qu'est ce que vous faites vous
harcelez tout le monde comme écouter
c'est normal si on braque quand elle son
mari tante olga que vous vous essayez de
alors vous appelez tout bon jour n'est
délivré que la toule c'est très dur pour
dépend des gens qui n'y sont pas prêts
il ya les couëts c'est plus facile que
tu y vas tous les quinze jours tu
t'habitues plein et tout le monde est
tué mais qui était pas du tout habitués
que tutu un joli 30 dit c'est vrai que
ça détruit book for les gens ça c'est
sûr alors vous vous allez très loin
parce que non seulement voir celer bon
les gens du rpr extra mais vous allez
voir chirac alger ni les bains alors
après on vous le reproche à bernard pons
qui vous a permis quelques places et
qu'elle ait dérangé le présent et public
mais vous êtes unique femme vous êtes
une femme qui aime on comprend ça très
bien non non on puisse aller je crois
que quand quelqu'un est capable en plein
meeting électoral devant un parterre de
plusieurs milliers de personnes
quand vous êtes enceinte de descendre de
l'estrade de vous emmener
à votre voiture de vous raccompagner
dans un moment où il a besoin de vous
jacques chirac
si vous voulez moi j'étais tellement
désespérée que je me suis dit je vais je
vais aller le voir c'est mon dernier
espoir je veux ils feront passer à autre
chose et si vous voulez je suis pas allé
le voir à l'elysée non plus je suis allé
voir un endroit qui était discret et
j'ai eu une fin de non recevoir
alors que quand c'était utile ombre
accompagnaient ont embrassé devant tout
le monde et j'étais la petite cocotte de
tout le monde alors la bomba vous partez
aux états unis avec pierre botton votre
mari mais lui quand il revient en france
il nous l'a raconté ici d'ailleurs quand
il revient en france non seulement il a
plus droit de sortir de france mais en
plus n'a plus droit de rentrer aux états
unis
donc il est resté en france et vous vous
êtes là bas comme on l'a dit aujourd'hui
vous êtes pas divorcer mais c'est pareil
alors il ya une chose aussi en lisant
votre livre qui est étonnante si vous
semblez plus facilement pardonné à votre
votre mari qu'à votre père c'est pas une
histoire de pardonner c'est c'est je
crois que ce livre il est vraiment entre
mon père et moi c'est tout c'était
vraiment pour pour essayer de faire
comprendre ce que j'ai subi
je veux dire je suis tombé vraiment très
très bas gg ça a été terrible pour moi
et j'essaye de remonter et si vous
voulez je voudrais vraiment mettre un
point d'arrêt tout cela c'est à dire que
je ne laisserais pas recommencer à
m'utiliser c'est pour ça je ne laisserai
pas venir me chercher comme ça en
m'envoyant quelqu'un jeudi pendant des
années mon adresse a toujours été dans
les procédures
mes enfants n'ont jamais reçus de cartes
pour noël n'ont jamais reçu de cadeau de
noël depuis 1992
park est déjà dans votre premier enfant
né il vient à la clinique et déjà vous
ne trouvez pas débordant d'amour pour
eux pour l'enfant non pour l'enfant oui
c'est ça parce que il était même il
n'était même pas capable c'est en
campagne électorale il avait ce terme il
appelait l'enfant quand il parlait à
quelqu'un parce que de peur de se
tromper de sexe et de prénom et je veux
dire il a appliqué sa petite-fille
jusqu'en télé n'est alors que c'était
c'était quand même un moment de joie
pour tout le monde alors quand votre
père essaie de reprendre contact avec
vous donc par l'intermédiaire de votre
soeur vous pensez que c'est une
stratégie pour les législatives de 2002
parce qu'en 2002 michel noir va être de
nouveau éligible donc effectivement la
question se pose
et vous vous croyez pas vous croyez pas
qu'il puisse avoir lâché la politique
non parce que je crois que c'est
vraiment un homme politique et que la
seule chose qu'il fait vibrer vivre et
c'est la politique je pense qu'il l'a il
a montré il l'a montré depuis en plus
dans cette affaire il a montré que
c'était la politique avant tout alors
maintenant vous avez fait ce livre pour
sûr qu'au cas où vous devrez continuer
se représenterait éventuellement ces
pour bloquer sa carrière aussi c'est
pour bien je vais vous dire c'est
vraiment pour que la vérité soit écrite
mention blanc et qu'on puisse cuir vous
donc si jamais vous voulez continuer non
moi la question je sais pas je me dis je
me dis la question que se posent les
gens qui ne regardent à ce moment est-ce
que vous jette ça pour qu'ils continuent
à être inéligibles bien sûr la femme
c'est de sa vie donc est ce que c'est
une une revanche qui ont un poids ou un
boulet mettra son pied ou est ce que
c'est juste pour mettre un terme comme
vous lisiez nageurs pour traître c'est
pour mettre un terme et si vous voulez
pas sa carrière aussi non pour mr non
c'est pour vraiment blessé le terme
peut-être très certainement vous savez
tout a été niée dans cette affaire donc
mais c'est vraiment pour pour que moi je
puisse recommencer ma vie c'est une
thérapie bon voilà c'est fait je veux
dire c'est ma thérapie c'est jésus des
médecins j'ai je pense essayer
absolument tous les médicaments pour
essayer me relever
j'ai deux enfants je veux pouvoir aller
de l'avant et si vous voulez moi je veux
par ce livre vraiment tourné la page et
montrer que je n'oublie pas parce que je
pense que oublier c'est accepter qu'ils
recommencent pas votre tête vous pensez
qu'un espoir de réconciliation c'est
justement est ce qu'on peut vous
éteignez la lumière chez vous est ici
aussi
alors la mairie noir la seule question
finalement que j'ai envie de vous poser
pour terminer ce choix est ce que vous
pardonnerai jamais à votre père est ce
que vous envisagez à un moment quand
même le pardon ça existe sur cette terre
est-ce que vous pensez que vous lui
pardonnera je ne crois pas il a gâché ma
vie et j'en veux plus voilà